[Music]
you got three quarterbacks who all want
out of their current situations deshawn
watson was the first one we found out
about not long after the regular season
ended and it looked like it was moving
in that direction until the first of
what ultimately became 22 lawsuits were
filed against him now we're in a strange
state of limbo as we wait to see what
will occur
one of the things that came out recently
and this was an item posted friday on
si.com cal mcnair
through the texans acknowledging that
his personal attorney contacted both
parties in the deshaun watson cases to
suggest mediation mr mcnair had no
personal involvement in any of those
discussions the texans organization has
not had any direct contact with either
party well they don't need to get
involved when the guy's lawyer is the
one who's trying to broker a potential
settlement and the texans have every
reason to do it number one if the case
is settled they can trade him number two
if the cases settle they don't have to
worry about the possibility of desean
watson reporting for training camp which
he will if these cases aren't resolved
and then possibly being placed on paid
leave where cal mcnair gets to pay
desean watson 10 million plus
to not play football this year he's not
going to play for the texans one way or
the other i wouldn't think so no
the question is if he's not going to
play do you want to pay him 10 million
no you don't now as i say that there is
there is
chris
one scenario
where he does play for the texans this
year he shows up thinking he's going to
get placed on paid leave
and he doesn't get placed on paid leave
that's the one scenario where he plays
for the texans
so wait what are you saying there he he
shows up
go ahead say that one more time
yeah cases aren't settled right okay
right training camp opens right cases
aren't settled he's not gonna hold out
he thinks he's gonna get placed on paid
leave so
end result same i don't have to play for
the texans but i get 10 million and i
don't have to pay back a bunch of money
i've already been paid in fines etc
because the moment i walk through the
door somebody from the league office is
going to say you're on paid leave yeah
he shows up
and they don't put him on paid leave
they they
let him stay
what's he do then right what's he do is
he leave once he finds out he's not
being placed on paid leave so
that there is a scenario where he
activates the season shows up for camp
and under the cba it's it's harder to
stay away
it's harder
to leave
than it is to never show up from the
standpoint of the rights you have once
you're there it's so much more difficult
from the from leverage and what you can
get paid and whether you can even play
if you leave and they send you the five
day letter and you don't come back after
the five day letter and they put you on
the left squad list yeah you play for no
one that year you get paid by no one
that year you are shut down for the
whole year so my point is he shows up
and he's not put on paid leave yeah he
may be he they may have five
quarterbacks in houston this year well
he i mean if that happens and they don't
put him on paid leave i mean to me it's
it's easy he just stays there you
continue you play football you practice
you put the pressure on the organization
to do something yeah it's gonna be a
media circus every day he's gonna have
to deal with that and balance out the
the stresses of that in his life no
doubt but that would be the play for
sure there you know and and i have a
hard time believing that it would get to
that point i mean you know i mean it's
not crazy i i know that but i would
think that's where the nfl
would jump in
at some point because they're not gonna
want like the number one topic to kick
off the 21 2021 season is desean watson
holding you know weekly press
conferences about this and all this and
this is the main thing in the nfl so
that's where i would find it hard to
believe but i i hear what you're saying
the personal conduct policy allows the
nfl to put a player on paid leave and
there are different circumstances where
that power
arises in the absence of criminal
charges it's a little bit more difficult
and if the
criminal complaints
that have been made by multiple of the
22 women who are suing him if that
results in a prosecution that's a
different story altogether it's easier
to justify putting him on paid leave
chris without a criminal prosecution
the standard is this when an
investigation leads the commissioner to
believe that a player may have violated
this policy by committing any of the
conduct identified above and for these
purposes the most significant of that is
sexual activity by force sexual assault
by force because there are two of the 22
women claiming that may have committed
is the key that's a broad broad standard
and it basically allows with all these
words in the policy it allows the league
to do whatever it wants
but but boy that would be an interesting
twist if he shows up believing he's
going to be placed on paid leave
and ultimately isn't maybe they would
trade him at that point maybe another
team out there would say hey if he's not
going to be placed on paid leave we'll
do it i think so one other point and
here's why i think there's some quiet
confidence in deshaun watson's camp that
he's got a chance to play this year
the way that the
the deadlines have been set up for these
lawsuits
they've agreed that he can't be subject
to deposition testimony until after
the next super bowl meaning that i saw
that
will not land on his radar screen for
anything he has to do until he's fully
and completely clear of the coming
football season yeah that that's uh
unbelievable i mean i saw that you wrote
that i can't remember if that was friday
or saturday on yeah friday that was a
shocking thing to see there uh because
yeah i guess my common thought was hey
you want to get this done i thought
maybe he'd do this here quickly
uh but it adds a different little
scenario to this this whole topic here
and yeah i don't i mean listen i'm i'm
i don't know where the hell this goes i
will say i do like you have said here
and you've heard me say this from the
beginning i think there's a number of
teams that are still
gauging this and watching this and have
still or just chalking this up a little
bit to like
like i've said before and sorry for you
know a horny guy with a fetish sorry
that's what they've kind of like a
little bit there is that i've heard that
from the start i don't think that's gone
gonna wet i don't know where this is
gonna go from here i mean sorry for that
tony busby who represents the 22 women
confirmed to si.com that he is the one
who is insisting on full confidentiality
right that is not the way it typically
goes it's usually the person who's
writing the check that wants
confidentiality and
regardless of
of why
busby wants confidentiality there's
speculation that maybe these payments
aren't going to be all that much at the
end of the day and busby doesn't want
people know how
little watson paid to make these cases
become resolved
point i've made recently and i think
this is an important one to remember
you don't get
to the point where you're talking about
whether or not the settlement is
confidential unless you have an idea of
what the settlement is going to be
there's no reason to have the discussion
as to whether or not the settlement is
confidential if you don't have an
agreement or something close to it that
tells me
that chris at any moment this gets
dusted off and this gets resolved
especially if you've got 22 women
who know that there's a number that
they're satisfied with to get this past
them and they can move forward with
their lives meanwhile they're looking at
a window that opens in september for
them to have to
sit for hours and hours and be grilled
about their allegations by lawyers who
have already said we don't think you're
telling the truth so i think at some
point before the first witness is sworn
in you're going to see a deal
that that may be between now and when
the first witness is sworn in for a
deposition that may be when these cases
resolve yeah mike's whenever that is
makes sense mike i mean i i hear you
there so we'll we'll see i mean it's
just crazy the whole story is crazy and
uh texans got you know some tough things
to figure out here and of course desean
watson the nfl they all got some tough
things to figure out
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports